[Música]
si alguno de nosotros tuviera la
oportunidad de saber qué va a pasar en
el futuro que sería lo que nos
interesaría saber
alguna gente por ejemplo estaría muy
interesada en saber cuándo será que los
viajes a la luna van a ser de un costo
barato y los podemos hacer cada año como
una vacación o quizá otros más bien
están interesados en saber
si tendré un trabajo en el futuro si
podría estudiar en el futuro otros
podrán pensar si cuando llegue a mi edad
de jubilación tendría una pensión pues
bien todo eso sigue siendo especulación
porque el futuro tiene la particularidad
de que no existe y el futuro no ha
sucedido y al no haber sucedido todo
esfuerzo de adivinación que hagamos
posiblemente sea vano y lo que tengamos
sea
opciones que no necesariamente nos
expresen lo que podría pasar en el
futuro
quiero contarles que la humanidad desde
el principio ha tenido esa esa inquietud
de saber lo que va a pasar en el futuro
de adivinarlo y se usaron diferentes
formas de adivinación y creencias y
rituales para saberlo sin embargo lo
cierto es que en los últimos tiempos
básicamente a partir del siglo 19
ha sido la ciencia ficción la que nos ha
puesto a pensar en cosas diferentes no
en qué va a pasar en el futuro sino en
las posibilidades que ofrece el futuro
entonces no nos esforcemos por adivinar
lo que va a pasar en el futuro sino
veamos sus posibilidades y las
posibilidades del futuro se definen a
partir de las decisiones que tomamos en
el presente
entonces hoy quiero compartir con
ustedes una idea que es también un
método que se llama la alfabetización en
futuros y alfabetización como tantas
suenan hoy virtual la alfabetización en
todo bueno esta es la alfabetización en
futuros cuando yo comencé a trabajar en
estos temas del futuro hace cerca de 10
años y alguien me dijo es que uno puede
usar el futuro a su favor yo dije pero
eso está un poco extraño no no veo como
ahora sin embargo hoy la sola presencia
mía acá en el círculo rojo es una
muestra de que cuando usted se pone una
visión de futuro
establece la ruta para llegar allá y
toma las decisiones correctas es el
futuro llegará si no si eso es posible
entonces si existe una forma de poder
incursionar en el futuro no cruzar los
dedos para que pasen las cosas que
ocupamos sino poderlo anticipar y la
forma de anticipar el futuro está en
desarrollar una habilidad fundamental
que la llamamos pensamiento disruptivo y
capacidad anticipatoria
existen diferentes formas de alfabetizar
en futuros la que yo quiero presentarles
es una en particular relacionada con los
laboratorios de futuro
laboratorio de futuro es un espacio de
conversación en donde las personas
tienen que tener claro cinco cosas y no
perderla de vista en ningún momento del
proceso de la primera
nadie sabe lo que va a pasar en el
futuro no vamos a adivinar el futuro la
segunda el futuro comercial albert
eisntein llegará y llegará a 60 minutos
por hora si toda la decisión que usted
tome tendrá sus consecuencias y las
consecuencias llegarán
3 es muy importante también el futuro
nos da señales o sea el futuro se
manifiesta en forma de señales algunas
muy débiles y otras más fuertes pero que
el importante desarrollo desarrollar la
capacidad para poder
visualizar esas señales de poderlas
interpretar
la cuarta cosa importante es que la
única forma que tiene el ser humano de
ir al futuro es anticipando lo porque no
podemos ir al futuro como la película
del regreso al futuro todavía no podemos
al menos entonces solo anticipando
podemos cambiar ese futuro y la quinta
cosa que es muy importante es que a
pesar de haber desarrollado toda esa
capacidad no todo se puede anticipar
pero si les puedo asegurar
que si usted cuando va a salir de su
casa en un día oscuro se lleva una
sombrilla puede estar mejor preparado
que una persona que no lo hizo que si
usted va a realizar un viaje de larga
distancia y revisa su auto revisa sus
aguas o aceite y sus cosas puede tener
un futuro diferente a otro que no lo
hace
y así sucesivamente
vamos a encontrar que todos los
esfuerzos para anticipar el futuro son
ya una forma de cambiar el futuro
entonces no se trata de adivinar este
futuro de ninguna manera sino de generar
espacios de conversación laboratorios de
alfabetización en futuro con personas
adultas los hemos trabajado sí a nivel
de toda centroamérica y han dado
resultados muy exitosos
qué es un laboratorio de futuro a las
personas se les plantea una situación
por ejemplo el desarrollo de un
territorio el desarrollo de una
comunidad un problema vocacional
etcétera y la gente empieza a visualizar
todas las posibilidades que podrían
generarse y para cada posibilidad que
retos tendría y para cada reto qué
alternativas tendría qué pasa cuando
esto se hace que cuando aquel evento se
le presente a usted en el futuro ya no
es totalmente desconocido para usted
porque su imaginación ya estuvo ahí sí
ya visualizo las las posibilidades que
se tenían
yo en particular
recuerdo con mucho sentimiento
cuando hicimos un laboratorio de futuros
en la en una comunidad indígena de la
zona sur de costa rica eran 30 muchachos
y muchachas de secundaria de un colegio
indígena
con ellos queríamos trabajar sobre su
futuro educativo y la pregunta que les
hicimos
fundamentalmente fue qué puede pasar con
su educación en el futuro
casi que todos levantaron los hombros se
volvieron a ver no tengo la menor idea
que puede pasar yo creo que yo no voy a
poder seguir estudiando a mí me queda
muy lejos somos muy pobres me están
esperando para que trabaje en casa para
que ayude a la familia es decir todos
tenían mucho muchos deseos de seguir más
sin embargo la condición actual parecía
que se lo negaba
entonces en el segundo día les dijimos
muy bien vamos a hablar ahora como
podríamos cambiar este futuro y ante
esta pregunta ellos le generaron una
ruta una ruta eso fue en el año 2019
ellos le generaron una ruta y dijeron
muy bien corre el año 2023
he logrado sacar mi título técnico en un
instituto técnico y ha logrado o he
logrado sacar una carrera universitaria
con esto estoy apoyando a mi familia
estoy apoyando a mi comunidad pero no
fue fácil tuve que superar y hacer una
lista de los retos que tuvieron que
superar todo esto no ha pasado está
pasando aquí en la imaginación pero para
cada reto así en una lluvia de ideas
diciendo podríamos hacer esto podríamos
hacer esto otro podríamos hacer aquello
tres años después de haber hecho esto
de los 30 estudiantes hay 28 de ellos
verdad que están
realizando alguna actividad de las dos o
están en una universidad o se están
formando o ya se formaron en un
instituto técnico qué quiere decir eso
que cuando ellos llegaron al punto en
donde no tenían dinero para hacer algo
esto ya lo habíamos pensado en el
laboratorio y cuando lo pensamos vimos
diferentes alternativas de qué hacer si
se presentaba una cosa como esa entonces
fuimos anticipando y al ir anticipando
no sólo cambiaron su vida sino que ya
cambiaron su vida porque cambiaron su
manera de relacionarse con el futuro no
lo adivinaron se lo construyeron
entonces si eso funciona si eso funciona
a nivel de
una sociedad como la que vivimos cargada
de improvisación cargada inmediatismo de
gente ahogada en deudas porque no tienen
una menor educación financiera como que
usted que funcionaría esto si nosotros
logramos
institucionalizar esto el sistema
educativo
es decir y eso distintos e
institucionalizarlo no se refiere en
absoluto alerta alerta roja no se trata
en absoluto de crear una materia y
dentro de las dentro de la malla
curricular que se llame alfabetización
en futuros en absoluto se llama
transversalizar el tema del futuro en
cada una de las actividades que se hacen
dentro del ambiente educativo no le
resulta a ustedes que sería muy
interesante muy creativo muy innovador
pero sobre todo muy atractivo para un
estudiante saber que las materias que
estudian tienen un contenido futurista y
que están dando una contribución para
una mejor sociedad pensemos pensemos en
ese estudiante que llega con ideas de
qué va el viaje en el futuro pero eso no
es un tema que voy a ver en la escuela o
en la primaria o en el colegio eso lo
voy a ver seguro con mis amigos pero qué
pasaría si ese estudiante que trae todas
esas ideas de su casa se encuentra una
como ciencias por ejemplo química
biología la física y en esta materia le
dice mire hoy vamos a hablar está la
clase de biología hoy vamos a hablar
seguridad lo que se llama el conteo del
genoma humano
y lo vamos a hacer utilizando en
realidad virtual sabían ustedes que por
medio del conteo del genoma humano es
posible saber las enfermedades que una
persona va a tener en el futuro y
sabiendo eso sabiendo esta información
podemos tomar las medidas anticipatorias
las vitaminas no ustedes los minerales
las cosas que aquella persona ocupa y
con ello evitar que suceda un futuro
como ese pues eso es posible y eso es
posible entonces no solamente que darle
es a esta capacidad de pensamiento en el
futuro y anticipación sino la esperanza
de que con un marco ético
suficientemente adecuado la la el
desarrollo la oportunidad que se nos
presenta es como nunca la historia de
utilizar todo ese conocimiento todo ese
saber todas esas señales para mejorar
mucho más la educación esto no es una
utopía
para para trabajar este este ratito que
he conversado con ustedes me dediqué a
estudiar los principales sistemas
educativos del mundo
donde se eliminaron los exámenes
memorístico se eliminaron todas esas
pruebas que se hacían antes y ahora los
estudiantes trabajan desarrollando
sistemas anticipatorios trabajan
resolviendo problemas comunes trabajan
formando pequeñas cooperativas en los
colegios trabajan proyectos de ellos
trabajan en equipo
y esto les ha permitido
una formación para la vida totalmente
diferente
no les parece a ustedes que eso sería un
ambiente educativo mucho más atractivo
niños y niñas adolescentes que de sus
pequeñas edades comienzan a desarrollar
la capacidad de anticipar el futuro
especialmente construyendo es el futuro
deseado
yo creo que sí es una gran oportunidad
que tiene la humanidad y creo que eso
trata este tema de la alfabetización en
futuros espero que haya sido de su de su
agrado y me despido diciéndole nos vemos
en el futuro muchas gracias
[Música]